ah
como están
hoy vamos a platicar de confianza la
confianza es el bloque fundamental que
permite crear relaciones esta afecta
profundamente cómo interactuamos con
otras personas pero también tiene un
gran impacto en cómo interactuamos con
nuestro dinero y los servicios que
utilizamos a ver levanten la mano acá
quien se ha quedado o ha sido un host en
unir bien vi
alguien algunos cuantos de ustedes se
han subido a un número por ejemplo
con califa están acá afuera
es cuando de ustedes por ejemplo han
pedido comida o super usando un servicio
como rápido conexión
y a ver esto es la más difícil seamos
honestos cuántos de ustedes han usado
tender ya no sean penosas varios lo
hemos hecho y cuando ustedes tienen
bitcoin acá en la audiencia pues
bastante de eso perfecto bueno
y todos estos sistemas tienen algo en
común estos crean conexiones interacción
e interacciones entre personas que no se
conocen y tienen un fin en común en el
caso por ejemplo del banhvi permite que
un extraño se quede en regresar a dormir
en casa de un extraño en el caso de uber
permite que te subas al auto de un
extraño y que hasta pongan sus vidas tu
vida en sus manos en el caso de algo
como rap y permite que un extraño vaya a
comprar cosas que tú necesitas y te las
deje en la puerta de tu casa y por
ejemplo en el caso de tender te permite
que conozcas hoy que conozcas un extraño
con el que posiblemente pases el resto
de tus días
el bien interesante como todos estos
servicios están creando estos nuevos
sistemas de confianza digital y estos
servicios mientras más crecen mientras
más personas se suben a este ecosistema
más seguros son y más utilidad le dan
por ejemplo si yo viajo a parís y en
parís hay nada más dos hay lugares en
donde me puedo quedar en unir bien pues
no va a ser muy no va a ser bueno para
mí porque pues a lo mejor no son las
opciones que yo quiero a lo mejor van a
estar lejos de donde me quiero quedar o
simplemente no me alcance el precio pero
hoy en parís hay más de 80.000 listings
esto quiere decir que hay una propiedad
no te puedes quedar por cada 80 este por
cada 30 residentes de la ciudad si yo
quisiera me podría quedar hasta en las
catacumbas de parís
hace más de 20 años que empezaban
empezamos a conocer del internet nunca
nos hubiéramos imaginado de todas estas
tecnologías y todas estas plataformas
que van a salir y como ya millones o
miles de millones de personas alrededor
del mundo están usando estás en su vida
cotidiana
pero por ejemplo cómo le hacemos
nosotros cuando llega a una de estas
plataformas cómo le hacemos para tomar
este salto
este brinco para tratarlas para darles
un chance como lo hacemos nosotros
cuando escuchamos una de estas
plataformas
no conocemos que es funciona de una
manera completamente diferente
qué es lo que pasa por nuestras mentes
lo que es bien interesante es que una
vez que les damos chance y tomamos este
brinco
se convierten aunque suenen loquísimas
se convierte en algo muy natural algo
que es completamente normal entonces
rachel botsman de la universidad de
stanford estudia cómo la tecnología está
afectando la interacción entre personas
y negocios cómo es que comercios como vr
giambi bla bla car son exitosos aún
cuando su por su modelo de negocio se
centra en ser un tipo de broker o
matchmaker entre completos extraños
entonces generalmente para que nosotros
tomamos estos saltos ella dice que
primero tenemos que confiar en lo que es
la idea la idea de que yo puedo comprar
un mueble de un extraño en san luís
potosí por medio de una página internet
y que esto es seguro y que vale la pena
darle chance después tengo que confiar
en la plataforma tengo que confiar que
si mercado libre que si algo sale mal
que el mercado libre me va a ayudar no
que me va a ayudar con mi pedido y que
me va a poder echar la mano
y por último tengo que sacar pedacitos
de información que encuentro en la
plataforma para confiar que el usuario
super machine 2001 que vive en san luís
potosí es una persona de confianza
entonces
muchas veces a la confianza es vital en
cómo nos tenemos que dar cuenta que la
confianza es fundamental para ver a
dónde vamos como sociedad está cambia
como interactuamos como personas y cómo
interactuamos con estos servicios la
confianza habilita cambio e innovación y
para empezar a ver esto tenemos que
analizar cómo ha cambiado la historia de
los sistemas de confianza a través de la
historia lo que es bien interesante es
que nada más hemos tenido tres etapas
importantes de sistemas de confianza lo
que es la confianza local institucional
y en lo que ahorita estamos entrando
confianza distribuida en un inicio
imagínense que nosotros 5
vivimos en un pueblito
pues yo le pido pre dinero prestado a
uno de ustedes
nos conocemos muy bien nos vemos cuando
caminamos y salimos está en la calle y
de repente yo no pago mi deuda del
préstamo que va a terminar pasando y ya
no me van a querer prestar dinero
y peor aún no van a querer promediar
conmigo y si yo no sé sembrar mi comida
o cazar no va a morir de hambre en los
últimos siglos el el mundo cambió
radicalmente las gentes se empezaron a
concentrar en grandes urbes y la gente
viajaba y se movía más entonces era muy
difícil mantener un récord de quien era
confiable y que no para mantener este
récord nacieron las grandes
instituciones
entonces el banquero local de pronto fue
reemplazado por los grandes corporativos
y nacieron estas instituciones hechas
para imponer autoridad y mantener un
control
de qué es lo que está pasando en nuestra
sociedad nosotros de pronto empezamos a
confiar más en las instituciones y menos
en las personas nuestras relaciones
personales ya no eran tan importantes
para como nosotros comercia vamos
internacionalmente o localmente
creo que no vale la pena decir como una
y otra vez las grandes instituciones nos
han defraudado como nos han quedado mal
como han abusado individuos que se
encuentran dentro de estas de nuestra
confianza
es muy interesante como
si vemos estas instituciones están
compuestas por personas y muchas de
estas personas muchas veces pueden ser
corruptibles o pueden tener intereses
personales sobre el bien común y muchas
veces se crean productos que exprimen al
consumidor o hay una serie de corrupción
o engaños etcétera o sea yo no vengo a
decirles que no necesitamos las
instituciones pero creo que si es bien
importante pensar como nuestra confianza
con estas instituciones ha cambiado
sobre todo en las nuevas generaciones
éstas ya no confían en la institución
se acuerdan ustedes de tener estos
libros horribles grandísimos que era
como la fuente de conocimiento cuando no
sabíamos algo la enciclopedia britannica
pues muchos de nosotros los tuvimos no
creciendo estas pues en el 2001 a esta
persona llamada jimmy wales se le
ocurrió la idea que el conocimiento de
las masas era mayor el conocimiento de
los académicos de los académicos que
están en universidades como oxford o
cambridge y entonces él creó wikileaks
él pensaba que el poder de las masas era
mucho mejor para poder compilar el
conocimiento del mundo para poder
compilar todo el conocimiento de las
personas y poco a poco
las personas mismas empezaron a filtrar
esta información filtrar la información
que dice la verdad y empezaron a sacar
toda la información que es falsa que al
principio le decían oye si me estás
loquísimo pero él pero poco a poco se
empezó a crear esta base de conocimiento
y ahorita es una es una base de
conocimiento invaluable para la sociedad
pudiéramos para lo mejor llenar cientos
de bodegas enormes con libros de estas
tomas que tengan el conocimiento que
habita este en wikipedia entonces desde
los primeros sistemas de confianza
distribuida que nos trajo la internet
pero hemos visto confianza en muchos
diferentes aspectos como la confianza
está afectando industrias desde
manufactura turismo educación logística
etcétera pero que de la industria o del
sector en donde la confianza es vital y
probablemente es el factor más
importante me refiero a la industria de
los servicios financieros y al dinero
como lo conocemos los días dirían que
nada
realmente es un sector que no se le
conoce por ser innovador pero si están
pasando muchísimas cosas y lo más
interesante de todo esto es que esas
innovaciones no están viniendo de world
no están viniendo de los grandes bancos
también viniendo de algún otro lado de
la misma manera que les presente de
diferentes plataformas que permiten
confiar en extraños ustedes le conferían
su dinero los ahorros de toda una vida a
su patrimonio a un completo extraño
yo creo que porque no no yo sí y mucho
más le confiere a mi dinero de mis
ahorros al banco es más
yo le confío pero no a más una persona
sino que a miles de personas que todas
participan en el mismo protocolo o
plataforma que yo
bitcoin pero cómo es eso bitcoin es una
divisa un protocolo y una invención
tecnológica que permite que por primera
vez en la historia se pueda mandar
dinero digitalmente de una persona a
otra persona sin pasar por un
intermediario financiero o por un banco
se acuerdan cuando les conté
necesitamos de las grandes instituciones
para poder transaccionar bueno eso ya no
es el caso aquí solo tengo que tener
acceso al internet para poder participar
en esto y ya puedo transaccionar con
otras personas sin pasar por el éxito
por una institución las implicaciones de
estos son enormes esto desde mi punto de
vista es la invención más grande para la
humanidad que hemos visto desde el
internet
mucho de lo que habilita este toda esta
tecnología es
el blog seno la cadena de bloques
algunos de ustedes he escuchado del
bloque salvo un par el blogs en es como
un libro contable que mantiene un
registro un récord de las transacciones
pero éste vive en miles de computadoras
alrededor del mundo
todas estas computadoras constantemente
se ponen de acuerdo que todo lo que está
pasando en la red si yo le mando dinero
a alguien esto se queda grabado en todas
estas miles de computadoras alrededor
del mundo y lo que hace esto es que si
yo quisiera alterar yo como pablo
quisiera alterar o editar este libro
contable no tendría que cambiar todas
estas computadoras en la base de datos
de todas estas computadoras al mismo
tiempo lo cual lo hace un sistema
extremadamente seguro y confiable
confiable de que nos dice la verdad
y ahorita es muy interesante porque hay
innovaciones que en blogs en blogs
inhabilitó innovaciones que van más allá
del dinero estamos viendo desarrollos en
registro de propiedades registro de
derechos de autor y patentes hasta
contratos inteligentes que intentan
hacer cosas como reemplazar un mecanismo
tan costoso como un fideicomiso con unas
cuantas líneas de código el poder de
esto es enorme pero todo esto suena
padrísimo el problema es que en méxico
tenemos un gran problema seis de cada
diez mexicanos no tienen una cuenta
bancaria tenemos el mismo nivel de
bancarización que eso mal
de acuerdo al banco mundial cerca de una
de las claves para combatir la pobreza y
elevar la prosperidad es la inclusión
financiera
esto habilita que las personas puedan
tomar control de sus finanzas y que
puedan tener un nuevo que puedan tener
un mejor manejo de dinero pero también
permiten que puedan comerciar más allá
de su presencia física
entonces esto es algo que si yo no tengo
una cuenta bancaria sólo puedo comerciar
con las personas que están alrededor mío
y hoy en día vivimos en un mundo global
en un mundo en donde ya interactuamos
con personas de otros países
en un segundo este desde una plataforma
tecnológica
pero la verdad es que contamos con un
méxico extremadamente conectado contamos
con un méxico
ya la mayoría las personas están
conectadas a internet están conectadas
es un país que se adapta de una forma
muy rápida a nuevas innovaciones
tecnológicas ya nuevas tecnologías
cuando nos ponemos a pensar en los
mexicanos decimos hoy estamos un poco
atrasados pero la verdad es que no somos
de los países más conectados para que se
dé una idea en sólo seis años
en los últimos seis años duplicamos la
cantidad de usuarios de internet el 80%
de las personas ya cuentan con un
celular y más del 80% de es de las
ventas de los celulares el año pasado
fueron smartphones
hay personas es impresionante pero yo he
conocido personas que han aprendido a
hablar y escribir usando whatsapp el
potencial para esto en un país como el
nuestro y muchos países en desarrollo
porque también esto es un problema
global es impresionante no sólo tienes
que darle acceso a internet para que la
gente pueda empezar a transaccionar y
permitirle vivir en este mundo un
poquito más abierto
la verdad es que el sistema
de confianza institucional para el uso
de servicios financieros nos ha fallado
ha creado un sistema en donde incluye a
pocos y excluye a los que más lo
necesitan
ha creado una oligarquía en donde hay
una cantidad de productos ineficientes
o sea por ejemplo a quién de ustedes les
gusta ir seguir un banco y pararse en
una fila dos horas para hacer un pago
una operación nadie es horrible todo es
bueno yo soy alérgico a para un banco
para hacer una operación en lo personal
como es posible que en esta era
tecnológica yo no le pueda mandar un
pago un amigo que lo mejor vive en otra
parte del mundo de la misma manera puedo
mandar un whatsapp a alguien en
australia y le llega en un segundo y con
la misma facilidad como es posible que
tengamos más de más de la mitad de
nuestro país siga guardando sus ahorros
abajo de su colchón
nosotros en beat son
creamos una plataforma que permite el
acceso a personas y empresas de esta
nueva economía digital de visión y
bloque desde que lanzamos hace tres años
hemos visto cosas bien interesantes por
ejemplo hemos logrado que personas
reciban remesas de sus familiares en
eeuu a mucho menor costo que pequeñas y
medianas empresas puedan mandar pagos al
extranjero que sean más rápidos más
transparentes y con el mismo tipo de
cambio mejor que una tele de un banco
una trasnacional que mueva millones de
dólares
y que también en tres personas que no
tengan una cuenta bancaria puedan tener
este puedan tener acceso al ecommerce y
puedan participar en un comercio global
esto sólo son unos ejemplos
y esto sólo es el inicio cuando nosotros
empezamos con nuestra tarea nunca nos
hubiéramos imaginado la cantidad de
casos de uso que esta tecnología
habilita y todo lo que vamos a empezar a
ver alrededor de esto en nosotros
yo tengo una cosa que me gusta mucho que
es cuando quitas fricción y das acceso a
las personas empoderadas a la gente o
sea cuando quitas fricción y das acceso
en poder as a la gente y ahorita la
gente no está empoderada y no tiene una
manera justa de hacer las cosas
estamos muy emocionados por lo que por
lo que viene pero si como país en méxico
tenemos que dejar de ser consumidores de
tecnología nada más y nos tenemos que
crear en productores de estos servicios
y plataformas que van a existir en el
nuevo internet de las cosas de valor es
hora de que dejemos de trabajar por los
servicios financieros y hay que empezar
a que los de servicios financieros
trabajen para nosotros gracias